The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation, or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
ERIK DEMAINE: All
right, welcome back
to Succinct Data
Structures, part two of two.
Today we're going to take all
the stuff we know about tries
and apply them to the main
motivating application, which
is suffix trees.
And as we know, suffix
trees and suffix arrays
are more or less equivalent.
But if you build one,
you can build the other.
But what we're
going to show today
is they're equivalent also
from a space perspective.
That will be the last topic.
If you can succinctly
represent a suffix array,
then you can transform-- with
a little o of n extra space,
you can make a
suffix tree as well
and do searches in roughly
the time we're used to,
which is p plus size of output.
It's not going to
be exactly that.
We're going to lose like log
to the epsilons and such.
But that's mostly caused--
this transformation only
occurs like an additive log,
log, log, log, log, log n.
You could have as
many logs as you want.
Take any arbitrarily,
slowly growing function,
that it will--
your space bound gets
closer and closer to linear.
Anyway, that's what
we'll get to at the end.
The bulk of the lecture will
be on building suffix arrays.
Here we're going to lose
a log to the epsilon
time in the query.
And we're going to start out
improving down to T log log T
space.
Our bottom line
is T log T space.
That's a normal-- if you
just stored a suffix array
as a bunch of numbers.
First we'll add another log,
then we'll get down to linear.
That gives us a compact suffix
tree, or sorry, suffix array.
That's also knowing how to
do succinct suffix arrays.
But there are dozens of papers
on this topic, it's kind
of a big field all to itself.
And a lot of the techniques
are pretty complicated.
So I'm going try to keep it
to the bare minimum we can do,
that will give us linear--
linear number, bits of
space give us a compact data
structure.
But before we go to
those data structures,
I want to give you a little
survey of what's known.
So compact suffix arrays,
and trees, start out with--
I'm going to start out
with the original results.
And then I'll jump to sort of
the latest results, which are
getting things to be succinct.
So the first result on this
topic that got a compact suffix
array, is by Grossi and Vitter.
This was in 2000,
spring of 2000.
And let me tell you the
bounds that they achieve.
This is actually the solution
that we're going to look at.
So this is the
first space bound.
I guess the big term
here is T log sigma.
That's how many bits it takes
just to write down the text.
So this is what you might
call optimal, in this world.
I mean, if you have
random text, you
need that many bits
to write it down.
So there's 1 times that.
We're also going to have this
1 over epsilon times that.
And this is actually
the data structure.
It's going to store
the text, and then it's
going to add on a data structure
of 1 over epsilon times that.
So it's order-- order [? ops. ?]
There's some lower-order terms.
We won't actually have
this lower-order term,
because I'm going to focus
on binary alphabet here.
Keep it simple.
But if you have a
non-binary alphabet,
they have another order
T bits, and so on.
But you get to
control this constant.
This will work for any
epsilon between 0 and 1.
And why are you interested
in a small epsilon?
Because if epsilon is small,
this space bound goes up.
Well, that happens
in the query bound.
So in the query bound, there's
this multiplicative log
to the epsilon of T. So if you
really want queries to go fast,
you don't want to pay
a big polylog here,
then you're going to have
to pay for it in space.
So those are the same epsilons.
In the Grossi-Vitter paper,
they only multiply this
by the size of the output.
So if you want to
just output one guy,
you only pay an additive
log to the epsilon.
If you want to output
all the matches
you have to pay a number
of matches times log
to the epsilon.
They achieve the P bound.
In fact, they do a little bit
better than order P query.
On a RAM, you can hope to do--
save a log factor by reading log
base sigma of T, of the letters
in one word operation.
So I'm not going to go
into how to do this--
I'm going to cover this paper
today, or a simplification
of this paper.
You might say, throw away.
I'm going to get a slightly
worse bounds than this.
Space bound will be the
same, but I'm not going to--
I'm not going to worry
about this log factor.
And in fact, both
P and output are
going to be multiplied
by log to the epsilon.
So I won't achieve quite
the best query bound,
but same space bound,
just to give you
an idea of how it works.
The next result-- yeah,
I'll go to another board.
These bounds are a
bit big, as you see.
The next result, which was
done later in the same year.
So these are
probably discovered,
basically at the same time.
Because writing a paper
takes probably a year or so.
So they were being
done in parallel,
and then this was published
in the spring of 2000.
This was published
in the fall of 2000.
It's called the FM-index.
And it achieves
this bound, which
is going to take a
little while to explain.
OK.
Think of this right now,
as this is T log sigma.
Ignore this H. This
is entropy stuff.
But if you think of
this as T log sigma,
we're getting 5
times T log sigma,
plus some lower-order term.
So it's a little less
flexible over here.
We kind of got to
control the constant.
Anything greater or equal
to 2 would be all right.
Over here, it's
always at least 5.
This has since been improved.
I'm just telling
you the historical--
these days people can get
down to at least 4 or so.
Actually, get down to 1.
We'll talk about it in a moment.
Before I get to
the Hk part, I want
to talk about the
lower-order term.
There's some scary
parts like this.
If sigma is that at all
large, this is big trouble.
Or even sigma log n--
this is a super polynomial.
So this cannot handle
very large sigma,
whereas this solution can.
And other structures can,
but this is an early result.
This also gets bad when
sigma's very large.
Even bigger-- when sigma's
bigger than log log T,
then this starts to dominate.
OK, but for sigma small, think
binary alphabets, whatever.
This is good, and in many
ways is actually better
than T log sigma.
So let me tell you about
this Hk of T thing.
This is what's called k-th
order empirical entropy.
Maybe I should start with an
aside of 0-th order entropy,
because we haven't
talked about--
I guess we talked about entropy
in the context of binary search
trees.
We said, oh, if you've got--
if you access item i
with probability P i,
then there's this entropy bound,
which is sum of P log 1/P.
So I don't know, let's
call this character x.
So if you-- let's see,
you have H0 substring s.
You sum over all
characters in the alphabet,
of the probability-- this
is not really a probability.
This is going to be the
number of x's in s, divided
by the length of s.
This is what's called
empirical probability.
It's what you observe
from this string.
There's this many
occurrences in the string.
You divide by the
length of the string.
That's kind of
like a probability.
It's scaled to be
It's between 0 and 1.
And if you take sum of P log
1/P, that gives you a bound.
And this is the bound achieved
by say, Huffman coding,
or the optimal code.
If all you're allowed to
do is give a code word
for each letter of the
alphabet, and then you
write down a binary code
word for each letter
of the alphabet.
And you write that down for each
letter in s, then you achieve--
I guess Huffman codes
achieve ceiling of this.
If you want to achieve
exactly that bound,
you can use arithmetic
coding, but we're not
going to get into
those kinds of details.
So if you used what's called a
0-th order code, where you just
have a code for each
character of the alphabet,
then the space bound you
would achieve is H0 of s,
times the number
of characters in s.
So that would be if you
substituted k equals 0 here.
So that's kind of neat.
This is a compressed
representation of the string.
Over here, we just
wrote down the string.
And if the string
is incompressible,
yeah, T log sigma is optimal.
But if the string is
compressible, like many strings
we want to store-- you're
storing English, whatever--
you should save somewhere
between a factor of 2 and 10.
This will try to save it.
Of course, factor
between 2 and 10 is not--
is a little scary, when
there's this factor 5 out here.
That might dominate
whatever savings you get.
But in theory, this
could be a lot better.
And this is just the first
result in this series.
Now we can get 1 times
Hk of T, and then it's
a lot more interesting.
OK, so that was
0-th order entropy.
What's this k-th order
entropy business?
Essentially, it's about taking--
instead of writing a code
word for a single letter,
you can write a code word
for a letter that depends on
the previous k characters.
So I'm going to write
down a definition.
Hk of T is going to be the sum
over all words of length k.
This is going to be our
context of the probability,
or empirical probability of w
occurring times the 0-th order
entropy of the string of
successor characters of w.
So again, the empirical
probability of w occurring
is the number of occurrences
of w, divided by T, basically.
So the idea is, now you get to
encode a character depending
on the context of the
last k characters.
So we're summing over
all possible contexts
of k characters, and we're
taking the expectation
over all possible context w.
That's the sum of the
probabilities times something.
And then condition on w
being the context, the last k
characters.
We want to measure what
characters follow that.
And there, we can use
a 0-th order encoding.
I mean, we've
already conditioned
on w being right there.
So for all occurrences of w,
you look at the next character
right after it, and you
take 0-th order entropy
of that, that's called
k-th order entropy.
OK, you have to think
about it for a while, too.
But this essentially
means the best,
you can prove this is the
best encoding you can do,
if the codeword of a letter
can depend on the previous k
characters.
Of course, if you have such a
code it's easy to decompress,
because as you're decompressing,
you know what the previous k
characters were.
OK, interesting thing about this
index or this data structure,
is it's independent of k.
The data structure
doesn't know what k is.
This works for all k.
For any fixed k-- k has
to be constant here.
There are other data structures
like [? KB, ?] logarithmic,
or so.
But here, we'll think
of k as a constant.
And so this is really a neat
thing about compression.
There's a technique called
the Burrows-Wheeler transform.
And Lempel-Ziv does
similar things.
You may have heard of
those compression schemes.
They're used in bzip,
and things like-- bzip
is named after
Burrows-Wheeler, I believe.
And those compression
schemes achieve
Hk of T bits per character--
so Hk of T times T--
for all k.
So if your text is
really good, given
the context of the last five
letters, or three letters.
In some sense, the compression
scheme adapts to that.
So this is what we call a
self index, in that this also
stores the string.
You can read the
data of the string.
And so whereas
over here, we just
stored the string uncompressed.
Here we're effectively
storing the string
in a compressed form,
and the data structure
is similarly compressed.
So if your string is
compressible by more
than a factor of 5, this
will be really good.
And that's the FM-index bound.
Now that you have that Hk
stuff, it's a lot easier
to state all other results.
So we have-- oh, I didn't
give a query bound.
That was the space.
Query is P plus size of output
times log to the epsilon T.
So, similar to this
one, but we don't
have this trick over here.
Another early result
is by Sadakane.
I think also, maybe 2001, I have
the journal referenced as 2003.
This is in some ways
better, some ways worse,
it's kind of incomparable
to the other results.
This is bits, and then the
query has an extra large factor.
This is again,
another early result
that I want to highlight.
Now I'm going to start
skipping results.
The main innovation
here, is that it
works good for large alphabets.
This is a very small
dependence on sigma,
whereas-- as I mentioned,
this structure really
doesn't work well
for large alphabets.
Here we're getting-- not
getting k-th order entropy,
we're getting 0-th
order entropy.
It's a somewhat weaker result.
The dependence on epsilon
is more like this one.
But if you just want
a log factor here,
then this is a 1 plus
epsilon times H0.
So in that sense,
we're doing better--
only a 1 plus epsilon,
which is better.
This thing was
always at least 2.
This thing was always at least
5, the complete constant.
Here the lead constant
can be 1 plus epsilon.
This is almost
succinct, but not quite.
It doesn't quite
compress as well--
it only uses 0-th
order entropy--
but that's still not bad.
And then the other
big innovation
is the dependence
on sigma small.
The query is a little bit worse.
OK, now fast forward
a little bit.
I want to talk about
succinct data structures
for suffix-tree-like queries.
So there's two succinct
data structures out there,
with more or less the same
authors as the first two
results I talked about.
So Grossi and Vitter,
together with Gupta,
can get Hk of T times
T, which is optimal even
with compression, with
k-th order compression.
And a good dependence on sigma.
Yeah, I guess--
T log sigma is the
uncompressed bound.
So you have to worry about--
when you're talking
about compression,
so here we have
the optimal bound
using k-th order entropy
with a lead constant of 1,
so that's great.
That's what makes it succinct.
As long as this is
little o of that.
This is going to be a little
o of that, as long as Hk of T
is not too small.
If it's like 1 over log T, then
actually this term dominates.
But as long as it's bigger
than log log T over log T,
this thing, then you're fine.
Just as long as you're not
compressing a huge amount,
then this will be lower-order.
Sorry, query time.
Query's a little
bit worse, though.
We have a log term with
a P, only a log sigma,
but then we also have this
log squared over log log.
Times log sigma,
and here I haven't--
there isn't a clear dependence
on the size of the output.
So this is-- let's say
size of output is 1.
You just want to find one match.
I won't write this dependence
on the size of the output.
My guess is this is multiplied
by the size of the output,
but it's not stated
explicitly in the paper,
so I want to be careful.
So we have a polylog
additive slowdown here.
So it's a little
bit worse in time,
but this space is
obviously, a lot better.
We've improved our constant
factor from 5, over here, to 1.
OK, and then there's
one more paper
I want to mention, by Ferragina,
Manzini, Makinen, and Navarro.
This is from just five
years ago now, 2007.
They also achieved 1 times Hk
of T times T as the lead term.
And they get T divided by log
to the epsilon n, so this is--
yes, it's slight, there's
probably a log sigma here, too.
I'm not sure, it might just be
T. Probably just T, actually.
So we get rid of the log sigma,
but this log log over log
gets slightly smaller.
It's only a log to
the epsilon now.
But the query bound is
a little bit better.
So the P plus--
as the output times log to
the 1 plus epsilon T query.
So instead of basically log
squared, we have log to 1
plus epsilon, slightly better.
They also have an
order P counting query.
So if you just want to know
how many matches are there,
they can do that really fast in
kind of regular time order P.
And this is
obviously very small.
So this is probably
the best result so far,
still obviously, lots of
open problems in this world.
Still an active
area of research.
There are papers
since these, but they
don't achieve-- the
space bounds they
achieve are not quite as good.
There may be like 2
times Hk, and then they
can get better query bounds.
A lot of papers that
I'm not talking about,
there's just a few too many.
But if you just care about
space, this is the best so far.
Or I use these two, depending
on exactly how big sigma is.
Just to mention, there's some
other cool things you can do.
So these are small space
static data structures.
Some of them can
be made dynamic.
But in particular,
there's work on,
how do you actually build these
data structures with low space?
Because you don't really want
to build a huge suffix tree
and then compress it.
Because the whole point
is you have a hard time
storing this data structure.
So in fact, there's
some papers--
I think more along the lines
of these original results--
the Grossi-Vitter, Ferragina,
Manzini, and Sadakane--
building those data structures.
And while you're building
the amount of working space
is at least proportional to
the size of the final data
structure.
So that can be done.
We're not going to
go into it here.
There are other papers about--
all of these papers
are focused on how
do I do a search, how do
I search for a pattern,
find all the matches.
There's other things you
can do with suffix trees
like, given two suffixes,
you can find the longest
common prefix of them.
So there's papers on how
to do that kind of stuff
in the compressed regime.
There's papers on-- or there is
a paper on how to do document
retrieval, which is a problem
we looked at two lectures ago,
in the string lecture.
You want to find--
not all the matches,
you want to find all
the documents that
have this substring in them.
So that can be--
that reduces the size
of the output in these bounds.
That can also be done, Sadakane
wrote a paper about that.
Some work on dynamic--
there's actually a lot of work
in implementing these data
structures, definitely
FM-index, and I believe,
maybe the Sadakane one.
And maybe this--
versions of this one.
I don't think the succinct
ones have been implemented,
although I don't know for sure.
But there's a lot of work
in implementing this,
because people care,
and indeed they're
small and reasonably fast.
So if you need a
text index, there's
freely available implementations
of at least some of these.
So this is one of--
I mean this is
practical stuff, too.
Cool.
But as I said, I'm going to
focus on the simplest I know,
which is Grossi and Vitter.
If you look at the
paper, there are sort
of successive improvements.
And we're going to
cover up to the point
where we get a good space
bound, and the query
won't be quite as good.
So that's going to be
the bulk of the lecture.
It's how to get
that space bound.
And as I mentioned,
we're going to start out
with a weaker bound, which
is getting T log log T bits,
and then we'll see how
to improve that to T.
And then we'll see how to
improve it to 1 over epsilon
times T.
So it will be a series
of improvements.
And we're going to
start just with thinking
about suffix arrays.
So what is the compressed
suffix array problem?
Well, it's just that I have--
I want to be able to do
queries of the form SA of k.
If I imagine the
suffixes in sorted order,
what is the k-th suffix?
Where does it begin?
So I want to be able to
represent that array.
And using that, you
could do searches,
and later we'll see how to use
that to make a suffix tree.
But for now, that's just our
goal, is to compute SA of k.
OK, well, the idea is actually
going to be very familiar.
We saw it two lectures ago,
when we did this divide
and conquer for
building a suffix array.
We did this-- we divided
the letters in our string
by 0, 1, and 2, mod 3.
We won't need mod 3.
We'll just do mod 2 here.
It won't actually matter
what constant we use.
But we're going to
follow that recursion
and use it to represent
the suffix array,
instead of using it to build it.
So the base case, and
set up some notation.
T0 is going to represent T.
The length of that string I'm
going to call n0 or n.
And we have a
suffix array, which
I'm going to call SA 0, which is
the suffix array of that text.
So that's just notation.
We're not actually storing
all of those things.
Now, the recursion
is T k plus 1.
That's going to be the next
level, which is, we write--
we combine two letters, Tk--
sorry, square bracket--
2i comma Tk square
bracket 2i plus 1.
Combine two adjacent
letters into one letter,
and we do that for i
equals 0, 1, up to n/2.
That's our new string.
I'm not going to
sort these letters
and remap the letters to
compress the alphabet.
I'm just going to leave
those letters alone,
as an ordered pair.
In general, at level
Tk, a single letter
is actually 2 to the k letters.
But still, this is a useful
way to think about it,
because it lets me think
about fewer suffixes.
Here, we only have
the even suffixes,
suffixes that begin at even
positions relative to Tk.
The size of this string, in
terms of number of letters,
is 1/2 of the original.
So in general, this is going
to be n over 2 to the k.
And then we're interested in
the suffix array SA k plus 1.
This is going to be just
looking at the even values.
So if we extract even
entries from sorry, SA k.
So if we already
have SA k, we just
take the even values
that are in there.
Those are the ones that
are existing suffixes.
Extract those, divide by 2.
That will be the suffix
array of this text.
This is kind of
backwards from how
you would construct the thing.
You would construct
it bottom up.
Here, we're
imagining-- we already
know the suffix arrays are
just about representation.
So this is a top-down
kind of definition
of what we're trying to store.
OK, so this is
what we want to do.
Now we are going to
build things bottom up.
We're going to
imagine we've already
represented SA k plus 1.
And now we need
to represent SA k.
If we can represent SA k
in terms of SA k plus 1
with not too many
bits, then you add up
all of the levels of recursion.
We'll have to talk about how
many levels of this recursion
we need to do.
We're not going to go
down to constant size.
We'll just go log log n levels.
But we just add up
all those costs,
and we'll get the overall
size of our data structure.
So how do we do
this representation?
I need to define two
kind of weird things,
and then we'll see why
they're interesting.
OK, the first thing is called
even successor sub k of i.
So let me define it.
It's going to be i if
the i-th suffix starts
in an even position.
So it doesn't do anything
for the even guys.
The interesting thing
is when the suffix
starts in an odd position.
Then we're going to write
down a different number j.
This is going to look kind
of weird, but it's actually--
it's simple after you think
about it for 10 minutes.
This one is odd.
OK, so the other
situation is that SA k--
the i-th suffix starts
at an even position.
So let me draw a little picture.
So here is SA of i.
OK, if this happens to
be odd, this position
in the text-- this is Tk.
Then I want to go here.
OK?
Because that's an even
position, it's a suffix,
it's right next to the
suffix I care about.
It is what we call the
even successor suffix.
But I don't want to
know the index of that.
The index of that would
just be SA k of i plus 1.
I want to map backwards
through SA inverse.
I want to know, what is
the rank of that suffix?
Which suffix j
starts right there?
I want to know that the
j-th suffix starts right
after the i-th suffix, and
I want to write down j.
We'll see why this is the
right thing in a moment.
We're just mapping
through SA, adding 1,
and then mapping
backwards through SA.
So that's a function.
We're going to store that
function in a particular--
in a very weird way, which
we'll get to in a moment.
OK, next thing we need
is called even rank.
This is going to be
like our rank function.
We've had it before.
This is going to be the
number of even suffixes--
even suffixes are suffixes
starting at even positions--
preceding the i-th suffix.
i-th suffix meaning the
i-th one in sorted order.
So the suffix SA of i.
Yes, so this is--
let me be more precise.
This is the number of even
values in SA k up to i.
So we're looking--
so this was the text.
Now we're looking at the
suffix array, which has
the suffixes in sorted order.
We're looking at position i
here, and we want to know,
of all of these values,
which ones are even?
Or how many are even--
that's the even rank.
Again, a weird thing,
we'll see why it's
the right thing in a moment.
Right now, in fact.
So here is observation 3,
putting these together.
This is a rather long equation.
Ultimately, I want to know--
I want to represent Sk of i.
I'm trying to represent that.
And I want the right-hand side
to only refer to SA k plus 1.
So here's the claim.
Take 2 times SA k plus 1 of--
I'm going to need another board.
Not of i.
Even rank of even successor
of i, minus 1 minus
is even suffix of i.
OK, so that's the equation.
Let me unpack this a little bit.
The idea is, we want to
know about a suffix i.
If i happens to be even--
sorry, not if i happens
to be even-- if SA of i
happens to be
even, we're golden.
Because that suffix is
represented by SA k plus 1,
but it might not be even.
So we want to round
it to an even suffix.
Knowing about this odd
suffix is just about as good
as knowing about the suffix
that starts right after it.
So that's what even
successor does.
This is rounding
to an even suffix,
meaning a suffix starting
at an even position.
Now there's this issue
that over here, we
have this relation between
SA k and SA k plus 1,
but it extracts
the even entries.
So if you think about the
suffix array, which now I'm
going to draw a vertical,
because that's more normal.
Some of these values
are going to be even,
but you don't really know which
ones are going to be even.
It's arbitrary subset of--
in SA k, our even values.
And those are the ones that you
extract and form SA k plus 1.
But it's an arbitrary
subset, that's kind of a--
you can't just divide
by 2 or something.
It's not the right thing.
If I'm given an index into
here, even if it's an even one,
I need to know what the
corresponding index is
over here.
And that, I claim,
is exactly even rank.
Because what position does
this cell become over here?
Well, however many even
numbers there are above it.
So you take-- that's what
this definition was, a number
of even values in that prefix.
That is the position you
will be in, in SA k plus 1.
So this is what I
would call the name--
we've now rounded to
an even suffix but now
we need to find the name
of that even suffix--
in SA k plus 1.
So that's exactly
what even rank does.
So now we can dereference
SA k plus 1 of that thing.
That will give us a
position into the text T k
plus 1, where that
suffix begins.
Now that's an index into
this divided by 2 string,
we need to uncompress that to
an index into the actual string.
And there are two parts.
One is we need to multiply by
2, because every letter in T
k plus 1 is two letters in Tk.
So multiply by 2.
And sometimes we
need to subtract 1.
We basically need to subtract
1 if if even successor did
anything.
If even successor essentially
moved us to the right by 1,
now we need to move
back to the left
by 1, if this moved us at all.
So I have one more function
here, which is is even suffix.
Was SA of i an even--
SA sub k of i, an
even number already.
Which means that even
successor did nothing.
If it did nothing,
then 1 minus 1 is 0.,
and so nothing happens.
If it did something,
then its even suffix
will be 0, because it was odd.
And then we're subtracting 1.
So this just means
subtract 1, if it was odd.
You might say minus is
odd suffix, instead of
1 minus is even suffix.
But it turns out, this is
the thing I want to store,
so I wrote it in a weird way.
Why did I write it that way?
Because is even suffix
is related to even rank.
Even rank is just rank
sub 1 of is even suffix.
And we already saw
how to do rank sub 1,
and so that's why I
wanted to reuse it.
I think you see now why
this equation holds.
What remains is how to
store is even suffix,
even rank, even successor.
One other thing that
remains, is to say
when to stop this recursion.
So I claim it's enough to just
do this recursion for log log n
levels.
And then I'll call log
log n l, the number
of levels in this recursion.
Because at that point,
n sub l equals n over--
it's n over 2 to
the l, so that's
going to be n over log n.
Once I have a string
of length n over log n,
I can afford the regular
boring representation
of a suffix tree.
I can afford T log T bits,
when T is only n over log n.
If you want to be a
little extra clever,
you can put a factor 2 here,
and then there's a square here.
And so then you're really
paying little o of T
in order to store that thing.
So once you get
down to here, you
can afford a simple
representation.
Now let's think about
how to compute SA,
like the original SA,
sub 0, of an index.
Well I apply this
formula at all times,
I do all these computations.
And now I've reduced
the problem to SA 1,
and then I do
these computations.
I reduce it to SA 2, and so on.
After l steps, I'll have
reduced it to an SA query
in a boring old
suffix array, which
I've just stored as an array.
So then I can answer it, and
then I pop up the recursion,
log log n times, doing these
adjustments as appropriate.
In the end, I get the correct
index into the original text T.
How much time did it take?
Order log log n time.
So I can do a log log
n time query to SA.
This is, of course, assuming
that even rank, even successor,
and is even suffix are all
constant time operations.
So what remains is
to do each of these
in small space
and constant time.
Then my overall query time will
only go up by log log factor.
This is actually going
to be pretty good,
we're not going to--
we're going to
achieve log log query
when we have T log log T bits.
That'll be our first
encoding of these things.
Later on, we're
going have to go up
to log to the epsilon, which
is worse than log log n.
Clear, so far?
Everything is pretty
easy at this point now.
It's going to remain
easy, it's just there's
a lot of pieces to the puzzle.
This is the first--
this is the big idea.
Next thing is some
fancy encoding schemes
to make these
things quite small.
Question?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] Did you
say what the space [INAUDIBLE]
was?
ERIK DEMAINE: We haven't
analyzed space yet,
because I haven't said
how we're actually
storing these functions.
If you stored these
functions explicitly, you'd
have bad space, probably still
T log T. But it turns out,
these functions can be encoded
in a clever way, that small--
smaller, it's going
to be T log log T.
And still has
constant time query.
AUDIENCE: Without the functions,
how much space are we using?
ERIK DEMAINE: Without
the functions,
we're using,
essentially, no space.
I guess, at the end
where we're using--
the only thing
we've said so far,
is at the end we use an
explicit suffix array.
And if you set this
to 2 log log T,
then this would be like n
over log n bits of space.
Because it's going
to be this times--
I mean, the space at the bottom
is going to be nl log nl.
That's to store an
explicit suffix array,
so it's going to be
this times log of this,
which is going to be n over
log n, if we put the 2 in.
So that part's really cheap,
and that's little o of n.
Of course, we probably also
have to store the text.
So that's n bits.
I didn't mention--
I'm going to assume,
I don't think we need it yet.
At some point I will assume
that the alphabets binary.
So I'm going to leave off--
when I say n bits, really it's
n log sigma bits, or n
characters, or whatever.
But I'm not going to
worry about that here.
Are there questions?
So now, it's an
encoding problem.
How do we encode these guys?
Actually, even successor is the
only thing that's non-trivial.
We're going to do the
obvious thing for the rest.
So let me tell you about
the obvious ones, easy ones.
At least, the first
revision we're not
going to do anything fancy
with them, later on we will.
Sorry, is even suffix.
We're just going to store
this as a bit vector.
This is 1 if SA k is
even, 0 if it's odd.
So if we just store
that is a bit vector,
this is n sub k bits
that we can afford.
Because this is a
geometric series,
it's going to be order n.
Next is even rank.
This is just the
rank one structure
that we covered last
class, on this thing.
So this is going to be nk--
I think we did log
log nk over log nk.
And this can be improved
to nk over log to the k--
or log to the something of nk.
But that's an OK bound.
It's little o of N.
Again, this is geometric,
so this overall will
be little o of n.
So those are easy, the remaining
part is doing even successor.
A little optimization.
If the i's where
Sk of i is even,
we don't really need
to store anything.
Because then, even successor
is the identity function.
So let's forget
about those guys.
I'll say, it's trivial
for even successors--
for even suffixes.
So what I'd like to do, is store
the answers for odd suffixes.
That's what we're going to do.
We're going to store them in
a weird way, as we will see.
So that's the odd suffixes.
There are nk over 2 evens,
and there are nk over 2 odds.
So we've just saved
a factor of 2.
This wasn't a very
deep observation.
But it turns out, if you
focus in on the odd ones,
has a nice little
structure to them.
This step isn't
really necessary,
but it saves a factor of 2.
Now the kind of
interesting observation.
What I'd like to do is store
these answers in order by i.
That's the obvious thing to do.
I want to store
basically an array.
Just store it in
order by i, so I'm
skipping the even suffixes,
just storing the answers
for the odd suffixes.
So if I was given a number
i, how would I look it up?
Well, given an index i
into the suffix array,
what I need to know is--
this is basically the inverse
of what we did with SA k plus 1.
SA k plus 1 is extracting
the even entries,
here we're extracting
the odd entries.
So all I need to know
is the odd rank of i,
and then I look
up into this array
at position odd rank of i.
That will give me
the answer I want.
Well, first I check is
is it an even suffix,
which I have stored
as a bit vector.
If it's an even suffix, I
do nothing, I just return i.
But if it's an odd suffix,
then I compute the odd rank.
How do I compute the odd rank?
I take the even rank
and take i minus that.
Odd rank, we don't need
to store anything for it.
I mean, you could
if you wanted to,
but odd rank is just
i minus even rank.
Because every index
is either odd or even.
OK, great.
So I can look up odd rank
and then look at this array.
That'll give me
the answer I need.
But I'm not going to actually
store this as an array.
I lied.
But in any case, let's
worry about how I'm
going to store it in a moment.
Let's think about i-- if I
I'm storing these answers--
the even successor answers,
these j values, in order by i.
I claim that order is a very
special order, because what
does it mean to order by i?
Ordering by i, that means the
suffixes are sorted, right?
So this is the same thing as
ordering by an odd suffix in Tk
from SA of i onwards.
That's the suffix that we're--
sorting by that suffix,
is sorting by i.
Now we can unpack
an odd suffix--
it has the first character--
and then an even suffix.
So this is the same
thing as ordering by--
this should look
familiar because we
did the same kinds
of tricks when
we were building suffix trees.
This is even.
In fact, it's the
even successor.
There's a typo here,
[? see ?] If we follow SA k,
and then we add 1.
If we follow SA
k backwards, that
was the definition
of even successor.
So I can rewrite this thing.
This part is the same thing as
Tk SA k even successor k of i,
closed bracket,
colon, closed bracket.
Get that right?
Yes.
That was the definition
of even successors.
Even successor is the value j,
for which if I do SA k of j,
I get SA k of i plus 1.
That's the definition.
OK, now Tk of SA of k.
Sorry, the suffix--
that's not Tk of.
There's a colon here.
The suffix of Tk
starting at SA k.
If I sort by those suffixes--
they're sorted, right?
I mean, that was the
point of the suffix array,
is to sort the suffixes.
So if I say I'm ordering by the
suffixes given in order by SA
k, they're already sorted.
There's no reason to do
this Tk of SA k part.
This is going to be the
same thing as the order
by this first letter, Tk SA
k of i comma, even successor.
The suffix array is defined
to have this property,
that these orders
are the same thing.
And sorting by the
suffixes is the same thing
as sorting by the indices
into the suffix array.
Interesting, because this is
what I want to store, right?
Those are the answers
that I'm trying to store.
I'm trying to store even
successor for every i
that has an odd--
that starts in an odd suffix.
So really, all I need to
do is order by this thing.
And then once I've
ordered by this thing,
I'll store these guys
in order by their value.
Cool.
So these are the pairs
I'm going to store.
I'm not going to--
I'm going to store this comma
this, for all i, in order
by this value.
That is my goal.
If I can store these
in order by this value,
then by computing
odd rank, I know
where in this list
of pairs to go.
And I just look at
the second value
of the pair, that is my answer.
Why am I storing this?
We'll see.
I don't know if you really
need to, but you can.
OK.
So what we're going to--
I feel like it's cheating.
I say, actually
store these pairs.
We're not really going
to actually store them.
We still have another
trick up our sleeve.
But more or less, we're
going to store these pairs--
I'll cross out, actually.
Store these pairs
in order by value.
Storing them in
order by value is
the same thing as order by i.
That's what we just proved.
And at this point,
is when I'm going
to assume a binary alphabet.
OK.
Maybe, I'll go through here.
Need lots of stuff.
Think we don't need this
giant recursion up here.
Just remember,
it's enough to know
how to compute even
successor, the rest is easy.
So here we go.
We're trying to
store these pairs,
so we're trying to store
a sorted array of nk
over 2 values.
That's how many odd
suffixes there are.
And they're each 2 to the k
plus log nk bits, I claim.
Why?
Because this was a
single character in Tk.
But a single character in Tk
was actually 2 to the k bits,
in the original string
for binary alphabet,
and general sigma to the k.
So that's that part of
this 2 to the k bits.
The even successor, well,
that's just an index
into something of size nk.
So it's log nk bits.
OK, fine.
If I store that explicitly,
I would be in trouble,
because 2 to the
k times nk is n.
And so I would be storing
n bits at every level--
well, so I guess they
get n log log n space.
That part's actually OK.
I can afford that
much if I'm just
going for an n log log n bound.
This part, not so much.
Because in particular,
when k equals 0,
that's going to
be n times log n.
I don't want to
spend n log n space.
And the whole point,
is we're trying
to avoid storing
these explicitly.
Because if I did, I'd
get n log n space.
So we're not going to
store them explicitly.
As follows, we are
going to store so there
are these big bit vectors.
We're going to look at
the leading log nk bits.
This is kind of weird,
because the log nk bits
we care about are at the end.
But we're going to look
at the leading log nk bits
especially, because this is
a sorted list of bit vectors.
So if you look at the leading
bits, most of the time,
they're going to be the same.
They don't change very much.
Leading bits are going to
be all 0's for a while,
and then occasionally
they'll increment.
How many times
will it increment?
nk times, at most, if we look
at the leading log nk bits.
Here's the crazy
idea, we're going
to use unary encoding,
unary differential encoding.
Differential encoding
means, instead
of storing a list of values,
you store the first value.
Then the next value,
minus the first value,
and then the next value
minus that value, and so on.
And unary means we're
going to represent
those differences in unary.
Seems like a bad idea, but it
turns out it's a good idea.
So here's what it looks
like, you look at--
I'm going to write down 0.
I'm going to write down a bunch
of 0's, however big v1 is.
Then I'm going to write a 1.
Then I'm going to write
a bunch of 0's, however
big v2 minus v1 is.
Then I'll write a 1, and so on.
0 to the lead, the
leading bits of v--
sorry.
It's the leading bits of v2
minus the leading bits of v1.
That's what I meant.
And then leading bits of v3
minus the leading bits of v2.
And then 1, and so on.
OK, that is unary
differential encoding.
I claim this is small,
looks kind of crazy.
But it's small, because how
many 0's are there total?
Well, at most, nk 0's.
Because I start at the value 0.
With log nk bits, at most
I get up to n k minus 1.
So the number of times I
increment is, at most, nk.
How many 1's are there?
Well, there's one 1, per value.
So there's nk over 2 1's.
So total size of this
bit factor is 3/2 nk.
So storing those leading bits
in this weird way is cheap.
Linear-- again, this
geometric series
is going to add up to 3/2.
All right, it's going
to add up to 3 times n.
Cool.
But that's just
the leading bits--
I need to store this thing.
I need to store
the leading bits,
and I need to store
the remaining bits.
Now the remaining bits, there's
only 2 to the k remaining bits.
We switched the order.
We looked at the
high log nk bits,
but then the low
end bits, there's
going to be 2 to the k of them.
That I already said was OK.
We could afford that--
kind of, we'd lose
a log log factor.
So we store the trailing
2 of the k bits.
This we actually
store explicitly.
So this is going to
be 2 to the k times
nk over 2, which is n/2 bits.
nk is n over 2 to the k.
Cancel, n over 2.
OK, so total number of
bits-- we add these up--
is going to be 1/2
n plus 3/2 nk plus--
we'll get to this later.
And then the total, this we
have to do for log log n levels.
We're summing k
equals 0 to log log n.
This thing.
And this comes out
to 1/2 n log log n.
This is bad, we want
to get rid of that.
But that was our first
aim, then we have 5n--
did I miss a term?
OK.
Where did I miss the nk?
This was the cost
for even successor.
OK, but there was also, is
even suffix, which was nk bits,
and there was even rank,
which was little o of that.
So there's an extra nk
here for is even suffix.
OK, so we have nk plus 3/2 nk.
That's 5/2 nk.
And then the 1/2
disappears because it's
a geometric series.
So we end up with 5n,
for what it's worth.
Plus big O of something.
OK, I left out something,
because there's
one data structure we
haven't yet described.
There's one more thing we need.
And that comes up if you want
to do a query in the structure.
How do I do a query?
I already did odd
rank, so I'm just
trying to look up into the
sorted array, at a given index.
Well, first thing is to
compute the leading bits.
Actually, computing
leading bits is really easy
if I have rank and select.
What I want, if I'm trying
to index into index i,
I want the i-th one bit.
To look at the
i-th one bit, which
is select sub 1 of i, which
we already know how to do,
then that corresponds
to the i-th value.
And in particular,
if I look at how many
0's are there up
to that point, it's
going to be the sum of this.
Plus this, plus this,
it's a telescoping sum.
It's just going to give
me the leading bits.
Because this plus this
is just lead of v2.
This plus that is lead of v3.
So they all cancel.
I just count the
number of 0 bits.
That's exactly the
value I want to know.
So I want to do rank
sub 0 of that position.
That will tell me
the leading bits.
In a query, it's not
really lead of i, I guess.
Lead of vi is what
we're trying to compute.
Now, we also need
the trailing bits.
The trailing bits,
they're just in an array,
so you just look that up.
You get the trailing bits.
You concatenate those
two words, the leading
bits of the trailing bits--
boom, you have your answer.
That gives you the
even successor.
So the only thing
is we need to store
rank and a select structure.
And for rank, we used nk
over log log nk space.
Again, that can be improved
to nk over polylog nk.
But let's not worry about that.
Item 1 completes.
We now have a T log
log T bit suffix array.
Next, we need to
make it order T,
then we need to make
it into suffix tree.
We're going to move
a little faster.
Where to go now?
Now I want a compact
suffix array.
I'm going to use
the same definition.
Everything's going to be
more or less the same.
I just can't afford to
store all these levels.
There were log log n levels.
Log log n levels
is too expensive.
Each one costs linear space.
So I'm only going to store
a constant number of levels.
Only store 1 over
epsilon plus 1 levels.
And not just any levels,
but the first level,
the epsilon l-th level,
the 2 epsilon l-th level,
up to the l-th level.
So it's still log log n levels.
I'm just going to
skip a lot of them.
Now, it's going to be different.
I can't use even
successor anymore.
Instead, even is
going to be replaced
with the notion of divisible
by 2 to the epsilon l,
instead of divisible by 2.
So I do all this, but
replace the notion of even
with divisible by epsilon l.
Because this is when you are
in SA sub k plus 1 epsilon l.
The whole name of
the game is, you're
trying to do a query
in SA k epsilon l,
and now you want to reduce
it to SA k plus 1 epsilon l.
And these are the suffixes that
are explicitly represented.
Everything else needs to be
rounded to that value, then
rounded back, like we had
with our giant formula before.
It's not so easy to write
a single formula anymore,
it's now really an algorithm.
So to compute SA
k epsilon l of i,
what you do is follow
a new thing, which
I'm going to call
just successor of i,
repeatedly to get a new index j.
Or I guess call it i prime,
make it a little clearer--
until it's even.
So before, we just
had to make one step,
and then we were even.
Now, we're going to have to make
potentially epsilon l steps.
So this could cost log log n.
Log log n, that's not much.
Actually-- sorry, not log log n.
This is going to
cost 2 to the epsilon
l, because it's divisible
by 2 to the epsilon l.
2 to the epsilon l is
log to the epsilon.
So this now may take log
to the epsilon T steps.
This is where we're going to get
the log to the epsilon penalty,
in time.
OK, but it's simple linear
search, nothing clever here.
Now, what is successor?
Well, successor is
just the same thing.
If you're even in this strong
sense, then nothing happens.
Otherwise, you just--
same definition.
This part is exactly the same.
Just go to the next
position, the next suffix.
But now we have to
follow it several times,
until we get to an even one.
OK.
Then we recurse, just
like before on SA k plus
1, epsilon l.
The next level down of the--
I think we can still
call it even rank.
And then we multiply
by 2 to the epsilon l.
And then subtract the number
of steps we did, in 1.
We made several
steps here, we need
to undo those steps at the end.
That's it.
So it's just the same as
before, except before there
was one step here, and
at most, one step here.
Now you just count them,
subtract at the end.
So exactly the
same template, just
skipping a lot of the levels.
And now the space is going to be
1 over epsilon, plus 1 times n.
That's it.
OK, so let me
analyze a little bit.
So you have to check
that all of this works.
Is is even suffix, that's easy.
It's still nk bits.
Even rank, still nk bits.
Even successor, we did
all this fancy encoding.
The one thing you
can't do, is this part.
I mean, there aren't very
many even suffixes anymore.
So it really doesn't help you,
it buys you a very tiny factor.
But 1 over 2 to the epsilon
l are going to be even.
So that's very few.
So you still have to store
all the answers, basically.
But you can do all this
ordering trick, it still works.
We weren't really exploiting
the fact that it was odd.
And now you have to-- this
is not a single character,
it's a bunch of characters.
But still-- and so now
instead of 2 to the k,
it's probably 2 to
the k epsilon l.
But it all works out.
It's just a renaming
of everything.
It's still going to be linear
number of bits, I claim.
I don't want to go through
a formal proof for that,
we don't have time.
But all the same tricks work.
So the claim is
space going to be sum
k equals 0 to 1 over epsilon.
nk epsilon l, plus n,
plus 2 nk epsilon l,
plus the select bound,
n over log log n.
Why?
Because this is storing
the is even structure.
That was just nk bits.
And then, this is the successor.
This is, is even.
Same as we had over here,
except there's no 1/2 anymore.
It's just n plus--
claim is 2 nk epsilon l.
That's the right answer.
Yeah, that 3 was because
of this, plus this.
So we still have the 3, just
don't divide it by 2 anymore.
So this equals some
constant times n, 6n
plus 1 over epsilon n.
Plus order n over
log log n bits.
OK, not bad.
Not quite as good as this
bound for binary alphabet,
so ignore the log sigma.
Before we had 1 plus
1 over epsilon, now
we have 6 plus 1 over epsilon.
Kind of running out of time.
I'll just tell you, you can
tune this to 1 over epsilon n,
plus the little o, with
two very simple tricks.
Two simple observations.
The first one is, the
successor structure.
At level 0, there's
nothing to do.
Why?
Because level 0--
a single step just
corresponds to
walking in the string.
I've got to think about
this a little bit.
Successor-- Actually not quite
clear to me why that's true,
but it turns out to be true.
It's an exercise, I guess.
At level 0, you don't need to
[? the ?] successor structure.
So that actually saves you
a big factor, because if you
can skip the very--
k equals 0, then you get to
skip-- you get to divide by 2
to the epsilon l, the space.
So that gets rid of this term.
Then there's this other
term, which you can skip,
or you can store is
even more efficiently.
So before is even,
should be a big factor.
Because half of them
are even, half of them
are odd, that's the
optimal thing to do.
But in this structure,
most of them are not even.
So you can save a little bit
using succinct dictionaries.
Because there are
very few ones--
you can achieve log, the
total number of things,
choose the number of ones.
[? Bog ?] of that binomial
coefficient is the number
of 0's plus 1's.
Not going to work it out,
it's worked out in the notes.
But if you store that more
efficient dictionary, which
we claimed could
be done last time,
then this turns out to get a
nice sort of cascading thing.
And it's little of
of n, in the end.
So that gets rid of this term.
And so you're left with
just n times 1 over epsilon.
Plus 1, because you have
to store the text also.
Or maybe because of
this plus 1, anyway.
Boom.
That's all I want to say
about this structure.
So I wanted to focus on
the ideas, which got us
the T log log T. Just
apply the same ideas,
but much more sparsely.
You lose in running
time, instead of paying
log log T. Now we pay--
we pay log to the
epsilon times log log T,
but that's just log
to some other epsilon.
So that gives us better space.
Now linear space, instead
of n log log space.
Any questions about that?
All right.
Now, I get to hurry through
transforming suffix arrays,
into suffix trees.
This is actually a
much older paper.
It's by [? Monroe, ?]
[? Roman, ?] and [? Row. ?]
There's two versions of
it in the same paper.
First version is going to
be compact, second version
is succinct.
Probably won't have much time
to cover the succinct version,
but here's what we do.
Start with compact.
Store compressed--
we're going to assume
binary alphabet again, as
this paper does, I believe.
Store the suffix tree, but
only store the trie part of it.
Suffix tree really
consists of trie--
binary trie, if it's
a binary alphabet.
Plus, lengths on the edges.
Don't store the links.
Or, as Ian likes to
call it, skip the skips.
The lengths of an
edge is how many bits
you're supposed to
skip, so skip those.
Just store the trie structure.
So the trie structure
is on 2n plus 1 nodes,
because there is n
leaves, and minus 1.
Telling me it's plus
1, I don't know.
2n plus a constant nodes.
So this is 4n bits.
We know how to do
binary tries, finally
we're using last lecture.
We use rank and select
a lot, but now are
using the binary trie.
We're going to store this using
the balanced paren structure.
OK, so you have to double that--
this linear number of bits,
so if we're just looking
for compact, that's fine.
Now the hard part
is in a search,
where we go from one
node, to the next node.
We need to know the
length of this edge,
we've got to figure that out.
We need to know whether
the pattern jumped off,
or something.
We need to know at position
y, which letter of the pattern
should we branch on.
So we need to
measure this length.
Not too hard.
What you do, you
look at this subtree.
You look at the leftmost
leaf and the rightmost leaf.
You look at their
longest common prefix,
starting from the
character you care about.
And you look at the longest
common prefix with the pattern
P. All sounds easy--
how do you actually do it?
So you need to be able to find
the leftmost leaf in a subtree.
Leaves in the balanced
paren expression--
I think last class, I mistakenly
thought they were that.
In fact, they are this.
Think about it long enough.
This was leaves in
the rooted order tree,
but what we care about are
leaves in the binary tree.
And they always look
like open paren,
closed paren, and closed paren.
So this is a leaf,
and so what we're
asking for is in a subtree,
we'll find the first leaf.
That's actually just going to
be right after this open paren.
Or, I guess, you do a
select, select sub this,
to jump to the next leaf.
Then also, you can jump
to the end of the subtree
and then go back to the previous
leaf, using rank and select.
So I won't go into details,
but that's easy to do.
So you can identify
the two leaves
using rank sub, this thing.
I can identify the leaf
number, so I can identify
where these leaves are.
Now, I have a suffix array.
If I look up the suffix array
of these two leaf numbers--
remember leaves are ordered
by suffix in sorted order
by suffix array.
These are really indices
into the suffix array.
They're giving me-- oh,
this is the i-th suffix,
this is the j-th suffix.
So I look at those two
positions of the suffix array,
I teleport over to the string T.
Now I have the actual suffixes
corresponding to this and this.
And I just look at
where they match.
I know that if I've already
gone down to depth d,
letter depth d.
I already know that they
match the first d characters.
I don't compare those.
They're guaranteed to match.
So I start at position d plus 1.
I know they should match,
but one more letter.
How many more letters
do they match?
That is the length
of this thing.
OK.
How can I afford
to pay for that?
I'm just going to pen linear
cost, the total number
of characters I
compare, is going
to be equal to the
length of the pattern.
So we're going to end up
getting length of the pattern,
times the cost to do
a suffix array access.
Because I have to do this
at every single step,
in the worst case.
So not perfect, but pretty good.
Roughly P, suffix array access
is like log to the epsilon.
So we're getting a P
log to the epsilon.
Not quite as good as this
bound, but because here the P
is not multiplied by
log to the epsilon.
But, it's just log
to the epsilon.
If you want to see a
better way to do it,
you can read the
Grossi-Vitter paper.
But this is a
decent way to do it.
Now briefly, this is
the compact version,
and let me tell you how
to make it succinct.
I'm not going to touch
the suffix array.
Suffix array, to make
that succinct is harder.
But if I just want to make the
suffix tree parts succinct,
I can use this same
idea, but I can't
afford to store the whole trie.
So just going to use a
little bit of indirection.
You can use as
little as you want,
this is the log log log
log log log log n factor.
Use the suffix tree
above every b-th suffix.
So throw away all but a
1/b fraction of the leaves.
And then, take the
tree that remains.
So once you do a search, you
won't find exactly the leaf
you want, but you'll
be within an additive b
of the leaf you want. b here
can be arbitrarily small.
This can be log
log log log log n.
But something super constant.
Then if I use this structure,
instead of being n--
order n over b space--
instead of being
order n space, it's
going to be order n over b bits.
So, we win.
The only issue is
now, how do you
find the correct leaf, as
opposed to the incorrect leaf?
I don't really have
time to talk about it.
You can look at the notes.
Rough idea is,
well, you can have
a look-up table that lets you
do whatever you want on b bits.
As long as b is less
than, like, 1/2 log n.
Then you can encompass the
whole trie, more or less.
And just hit it with
a big look-up table
and do everything
in constant time.
It's not quite so
simple, because--
easy summary, here.
Essentially, what
you're doing is--
these are the blocks.
So this is length b.
You're finding this suffix,
and you want to know,
which of these is
the correct one.
In some sense, you have to
do the search simultaneously
for all b of these guys.
And so you run down
the search again,
but instead of searching
for one pattern,
you search for all b of these
patterns at the same time.
Now they're mostly the
same, and so you can
prove it doesn't hurt you much.
Maybe it hurts
you an additive b.
I believe the correct answer
is, in time, you end up
paying quarter p plus b time.
Sorry, times the cost of
a suffix array access.
OK, so we're still paying
the log to the epsilon,
because of the suffix array.
If that was constant,
it would be free.
P plus b time is fine, if
b is log log log log n.
Or you can make it log log n.
Then you save a log log
n factor in the bits.
You pay an additive log log n.
That's going to be absorbed by
the log to the epsilon anyway.
So it's pretty efficient.
I guess you can make
this log to the epsilon,
if you felt like it,
to balance out here.
Still would be P times
log to the epsilon.
And so this stuff is
really quite cheap,
see the notes for details.
That ends our succinct coverage.
Sorry, it was a little more
succinct than intended.
Get the idea.